THAT EMPTY MIDDLE SEAT.
BRIAN: I AGREE.
STEVE: THEY SAID WE WILL NOT
CHARGE PEOPLE FOR THAT.
LET’S BRING IN TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
DAN CRENSHAW, FORMER NAVY SEAL,
AMERICAN RESILIENCE.
HE JOINS US FROM HIS LOCATION.
CONGRESSMAN, BECAUSE YOU’RE
REPRESENTING A DISTRICT IN TEXAS
I WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT
SHELLEY LUTHER, SALON OWNER WHO
SAID, LOOK, I HAVE TO REOPEN.
I KNOW I CAN’T OPEN RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I HAVE TO DO IT BECAUSE
I HAVE TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE.
SHE WAS HELD -- SHE WAS ISSUED A
CEASE AND DESIST ORDER.
SHE TORE IT UP FAMOUSLY AT
PUBLIC DEMONSTRATION AND IN
FRONT OF A JUDGE THE JUDGE SAYS
YOU WANT TO APOLOGIZE, SHE SAID,
NO.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH YOU,
SIR, WHEN YOU SAY THAT I’M
SELFISH BECAUSE FEEDING MY KIDS
IS NOT SELFISH.
I HAVE HAIR STYLISTS THAT ARE
GOING HUNGRY BECAUSE THEY RATHER
FEED THEIR KIDS.
IF YOU THINK THE LAW IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN KIDS GETTING FED,
-- STEVE: CONGRESSMAN, IT SEEMS
LIKE WHAT EVERY PARENT WOULD DO.
WE KNOW THAT A GOFUNDME PAGE HAS
STARTED AND OVER HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS HAS BEEN RAISED FOR HER
SO FAR.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> THE SO-CALLED COUNTRY AND
SO-CALLED LEADERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARRESTING AND GUY IN
FLORIDA SENT TO COURT BECAUSE
SELF-TAKEOUT IN A RESTAURANT AND
IS HAPPENING OVER AND OVER.
IS SO-CALLED LEADERS AND
SO-CALLED JUDGES WILL NEED TO
TAKE CIVICS LAWS.
PEOPLE ARE NOT DUMB AND THEY CAN
UNDERSTAND WHETHER A LAW MAKES
SENSE OR REALLY BASED ON DATA
AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND A LOT OF
THESE THINGS AREN’T.
WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF RULES
BEING PASSED THAT SIMPLE YOU
DON’T MAKE SENSE AND THEN THEY
GO FURTHER, THEY WANT TO
ACTUALLY PUNISH YOU, THEY WANT
TO USE THE FULL FORCE OF THE
LAW, FINE YOU, THROW YOU IN
JAIL, ARREST YOU, TAKE AWAY YOUR
FREEDOM BECAUSE YOU’RE ENGAGING
IN ACTIVITY THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
PERFECTLY LEGAL.
ENGAGING WITH INVOLUNTARY
TRANSACTION WITH ANOTHER HUMAN
BEING HAS BEEN LEGAL ACTIVITY
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN MAKE IT
ILLEGAL AND USE THE FULL FORCE
OF THE LAW TO ENFORCE IT.
THAT GOES AGAINST VERY BASIC
VALUES.
I’M ALL FOR THE GUIDELINES,
OKAY, BUT THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO
USE THE LIGHTEST TOUCH POSSIBLE
AND THESE SO-CALLED LEADERS ARE
NOT DOING THAT, THEY ARE
INFRINGING ON PEOPLE’S FREEDOMS
ALL WHILE BY THE WAY ADVOCATING
TO ALLOW OTHER CRIMINALS WHO
HAVE PREVIOUSLY BEEN IN JAIL TO
BE RELEASED.
IT’S CONTRADICTORY AND WHAT OUR
SOCIETY IS FOUNDED UPON.
BRIAN: I WILL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE, WHY CAN’T YOU GO TO A
CAR WASH, WHY CAN’T A JEWELRY
STORE OPEN UP ON MOTHER’S DAY TO
SUSTAIN BUSINESS, WHY CAN’T THE
LIQUOR STORE BE OPENED AND WHY
CAN’T I GO TO A SUPER MARKET BUT
I CAN’T GO TO A SPORTS STORE?
WHY DO THEY EXPECT PEOPLE TO
THINK IT’S RATIONALIZED
BEHAVIOR?
WHY DO THEY THINK I CAN’T WALK
ON THE BEACH OR SIT ON THE
BEACH?
HOW DARE I SIT ON THE BEACH, I
COULD GET A FINE AS OPPOSED TO
66% OF THE PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO
ARE SHELTERED IN PLACE.
>> THEY ARE DRUNK ON POWER.
THEY THINK WE ARE STUPID.
THEY THINK WE ARE STUPID AND
DRUNK ON POWER.
THIS IS WHY YOU ARE SEEING
PEOPLE RISE UP.
AMERICANS ARE SICK OF IT.
SENSE OF SO-CALLED LEADERS,
SO-CALLED JUDGES, THEY HAVE A
SENSE THAT THEY ARE NOT ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING THE LAWS BECAUSE
THESE AREN’T LAWS, THESE ARE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
THEY HAVE A SENSE OF NOT
IMPLEMENTING JUSTICE AS WINCE IT
AS CULTURE AND SOCIETY.
WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE DOING THE
RIGHT THING AND WE HAVE TO CALL
THEM OUT FOR IT.
AINSLEY: DAN, CONGRESSMAN, I
KNOW THE HOUSE IS THINKING ABOUT
DRAFTING A NEW RELIEF BILL,
NANCY PELOSI HAS TALKED ABOUT IT
BEING ONE TRILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP HEALTHCARE WORKERS, FIRST
RESPONDERS, POSTAL WORKERS AND
TEACHERS.
WHAT DO THE REPUBLICANS THINK
ABOUT THIS AND WOULD THERE BE
ANOTHER RELIEF BILL AND HOW
MUCH?
>> LISTEN, FIRST OF ALL, THE WAY
WE NEED TO ASSESS FUTURE RELIEF
BILLS IS ONE PROBLEM AT A TIME
WITH ONE SOLUTION AT A TIME.
WE COULD HAVE BEEN IN CONGRESS
IN THE HOUSE WORKING THIS WHOLE
TIME.
NANCY PELOSI WANTS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
ONLY ALLOWED TO GO AND WORK ONCE
EVERY 3 WEEKS AND PASS MULTIPLE
TRILLION DOLLAR BILLS.
HERE IS THEIR PLAYBOOK, THEY
WANT YOU TO STAY LOCK DOWN AND
ARREST YOU IF YOU DON’T, THEY
WANT TO WAIT FOR INDUSTRIES TO
FAIL SO THERE’S NO JOBS TO GO
BACK TO AND THEY WANT TO ACT
LIKE RULERS AND OFFER YOU MONEY.
WHOSE MONEY IS THAT?
YOUR MONEY.
IT’S GOING TO BE YOUR TAXES THAT
HAVE TO BE RAISED AND IN 2020,
2020 ELECTIONS DEMOCRATS WILL
COME BACK AND SAID LOOK HOW
GENEROUS WE WERE WITH YOUR
MONEY.
THAT’S THEIR PLAYBOOK.
WE HAVE TO WAKE UP TO THIS.
THIS IS NOT RESPONSIBLE
GOVERNANCE.
THERE ISN’T SOME UNLIMITED
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO BE SPENDING
ESPECIALLY TO BAIL OUT STATES
THAT HAVE BEEN TERRIBLY WITH
THEIR FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY THIS
ENTIRE TIME.
OKAY, IF YOU’RE A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS FROM TEXAS, I DON’T SEE
HOW YOU WANT TO USE TEXAN
FEDERAL TAX DOLLARS THAT WE ARE
PAYING TO BAIL OUT OTHER STATE
THAT IS HAVE BEEN TOTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE ALL THIS TIME.
THAT’S THE STUFF THAT’S GOING TO
BE PUT INTO THIS.
IT’S GOING TO BE ENORMOUS.
NOT HOW WE SHOULD BE GOVERNING,
DISCREET SOLUTIONS FOR DISCREET
PROBLEMS.
HONEST DEBATE IN THE HOUSE.
THAT’S WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
WE HAVE TAKEN PERFECTLY SAFE
MEASURES IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
STEVE: CONGRESSMAN, SPEAKING OF
RESPONSIBLE, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
WONDERING WERE RESPONSIBLE
THINGS BEING DONE BEHIND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND FBI TO
FORWARD THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
AND ULTIMATELY REFOUND OUT A
LITTLE MORE YESTERDAY WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RELEASED
ONCE AGAIN A REDACTED VERSION OF
ONE
ONE OF THE SCOPE MEMOS THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN HAD GIVEN TO ROBERT
MUELLER REGARDING WHAT HE COULD
LOOK TO AND AMONG OTHER THINGS,
PART OF THE SCOPE MEMO FROM
AUGUST 2ND, 2017 SAID LOOK FOR
ANY LINKS AND/OR COORDINATIONS
WITH RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OR
INDIVIDUALS ASSOCIATED WITH
CAMPAIGN OF DONALD TRUMP AND
SECONDLY, ANY MATTERS THAT AROSE
OR MAY ARISE DIRECTLY FROM THAT
INVESTIGATION.
THERE WERE FOUR NAMES ON IT,
CARTER PAGE, PAUL MANAFORT,
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS AND MICHAEL
FLYNN AND TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
THEY WE WANTED TO KNOW WHAT THE
SCOPE WAS, HOW BROAD WAS HIS
SUPPORT?
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WAS QUITE BROAD
BECAUSE SOME THINGS PANNED OUT
AND A LOT OF STUFF DID NOT.
>> RIGHT, AND HERE IS THE BEST
WAY TO SUMMARIZE WHAT’S GOING ON
HERE.
THIS WAS AN INVESTIGATION IN
CERTAINLY OF A CRIME.
THAT SHOULD TERRIFY AMERICANS
AND THE MORE WE FIND OUT ABOUT
THE ENTIRE PROBE, NARRATIVE THAT
WAS SPUN FOR YEARS, TRICKING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BO -- INTO
THINKING THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
A RUSSIAN PUPPET.
THEY HAD AN IDEA, A CONCLUSION,
A CRIME THAT THEY WANTED TO
PROVE AND THEY GAVE THEMSELVES
THE POWER TO TRY TO PROVE IT.
THIS IS A HORRIBLE, HORRIBLE
PRECEDENCE TO SET.
THIS GOES AGAINST JURIES
PRUDENCE, LAW AND PROCESS AND
ADDED ON TOP OF THE FISA WARRANT
ABUSE.
IT’S ADDED ON TOP OF WHAT WE
JUST FOUND OUT ABOUT GENERAL
FLYNN AND HOW THE FBI TRIED TO
AMBUSH HIM.
IT’S ADDED ON TOP OF WHAT WE
KNOW NOW ABOUT THE STEELE
DOSSIER AND HOW IT WAS USED AS
OPPOSED OF EVIDENCE TO
INVESTIGATE THE SUPPOSED CRIMES.
IT SHOULD REALLY TERRIFY
AMERICANS AND I HOPE MORE PEOPLE
REALIZE THIS.
REMEMBER, YOU WERE -- YOU WERE
DRAGGED BY THE MEDIA THROUGH
THIS CRAZY NARRATIVE, THIS CRAZY
ROLLER COASTER FOR YEARS AND IT
WAS ALL HOUSE OF CARDS.
NONE OF -- IT TURNS OUT NONE OF
IT WAS TRUE AND WHO DID THIS, IT
WAS ALL POLITICALLY BIAS.
THERE WAS ALL CONFIRMATION BIAS
FROM THE DOJ OFFICIALS FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE
THEY HATED TRUMP SO BADLY AND
THEY -- THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY
-- THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
EXERTING SOME KIND OF JUSTICE
AGAINST THIS MAN BUT IN TEND,
THEY WERE THE ONES BREAKING THE
LAW AND BREAKING OUR TRUST.
BRIAN: DAN READING YOUR BOOK
FORTITUDE, YOU TALK ABOUT BAN OF
BROTHERS, I’M WONDERING HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT THE FBI STICKING
TOGETHER, WE ARE SEEING TERRIBLE
BEHAVIOR, MCCABE AND STRZOK AND
PAGE, AND COMEY, THE WAY THEY
ACTED FROM THE SEVENTH FLOOR AS
OPPOSED TO THE WAY THAT IT’S
REALLY RUN IN THE BUREAU.
WHY HAVEN’T THERE BEEN FBI
WHISTLEBLOWERS AND GO IN THE
SAME MIND SET THAT YOU HAVE IN
THE SPECIAL FORCES?
>> DAN: I DON’T KNOW.
I DO KNOW A LOT OF FBI AGENTS
THAT ARE REALLY GREAT PEOPLE SO
I WANT TO GIVE THEM THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT LIKE U.S. STOCK
MARKET FUTURES JUST LIKE IN THE
SEAL TEAM WE GET BAD APPLES AND
EMBARRASS THE SEAL COMMUNITY.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE INSTITUTION.
BRIAN: BUT THEY ARE NOT.
>> DAN: THEY SHOULD BE.
I’M AGREEING WITH YOU.
I WISH I COULD TELL YOU MORE, I
JUST CAN’T.
I THINK THEY NEED TO MAN UP AND
ACTUALLY GET RID OF SOME OF THE
BAD ACTORS WHO HAVE CLEARLY BIAS
AND CONFIRMATION BIAS AND
COMPLETELY THROWN AWAY DUE
PROCESS AND RULE OF LAW TO DO